bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat
à suivre cet après-midi l'audition de
manuel valls le ministre de l'intérieur
est entendu par la commission des lois
présidée par le sénateur socialiste
jean-pierre sueur au programme de cette
audition la politique en matière
d'immigration
le ministre de l'intérieur a récemment
déclaré être de gauche ce n'est pas
obligatoirement régulariser tous les
sans papiers
alors quelles vont être les critères
retenus
quelle va être la politique du
gouvernement en matière d'immigration
tout de suite direction la salle médicis
en bien mes chers collègues
merci mesdames et messieurs merci d'être
venus à cette audition
et merci à manuel valls monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur d'avoir bien
voulu accepter de répondre à nos
questions et d'abord de nous présenter
dans un exposé liminaire les
orientations de la politique de
l'immigration
je voulais monsieur le ministre présenté
les excuses d'un certain nombre de nos
collègues car nous avons dû pour des
raisons tout à fait indépendante de
votre volonté que nous comprenons très
bien il ya eu je prends un conseil de
défense soumis ce midi à l'elysée nous
avons dû déplacer l'horaire mais nous
tenions absolument je sais que vous
teniez aussi à cette rencontre
c'est pourquoi certains collègues sont
retenus par la loi de finances
rectificative
d'autre part deux réunions de
commissions une réunion des délégations
donc chacun
fait au mieux mais un grand nombre de
collègues vous le voyez particulièrement
préoccupés intéressés par les sujets de
l'immigration sont sont venus nous avons
souhaité nous aurons l'occasion de nous
revoir sans nul doute monsieur le
ministre il ya bien d'autres sujets dont
vous avez la charge les questions de
sécurité les questions relatives au mode
d'élection à l'organisation de l'état et
c'est eux
nous avons eu souhaité eux concentrés
cette audition si vous vous en étiez
d'accord sur les questions de
l'immigration y compris pour nous la
question du droit d'asile est une autre
question le droit d'asile n'est pas un
appendice à la politique d'immigration
il a une politique d'immigration
puis il ya un droit et le droit d'asile
donc sur ces questions d'immigration
nous allons tout de suite vous écoutez
si vous voulez bien pour cet exposé
liminaire monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs jeu tient
évidemment à vous remercier de m'avoir
convié cette année cet après midi à
m'exprimer devant vous et pour présenter
en effet les axes que le gouvernement
entend mener en matière d'immigration
noize d'asile nous y reviendrons donc à
vos demandes d'intégration ou d'accès à
la nationalité
c'est la première fois que je m'adresse
à vous dans mes fonctions de ministre de
l'intérieur
je voudrais vous faire part de l'état
d'esprit d'abord qui qui m'anime j'ai
été parlementaire pendant dix ans et je
connais évidemment à ce titre
l'importance du travail en commission
qui permet d'affiner les perceptions
d'apporter les éclairages essentielles
sur les problèmes et donc soyez assuré
monsieur le président car votre
invitation je prendrai toute ma part aux
travaux pour lesquels vous souhaiterez
m'associer gtli à deux semaines devant
la commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale et je fais pas évidemment à
vos collègues députés de la même volonté
je suis
également disponible vis-à-vis du
parlement européen je vous dire qu'au
début du mois je me suis rendu à
strasbourg
je suis très attaché au principe de
libre circulation est une manière
d'entrer dans le propos je serai aussi
très scrupuleux quant à la préservation
de l'acquis schengen
je refuse la fermeture unilatérale des
frontières et tout doit être décidé par
le conseil sur proposition de la
commission et je refuserais évidemment
la politique de la chaise vide
si je n'obtiens pas satisfaction
contrairement à ce qu'a pu être dit
d'ailleurs compris par des sénateurs
je n'ai absolument pas accepter un
compromis correspondant à ce que
souhaitait le précédent gouvernement pas
par principe mais parce que ce sont les
faits mais dans le même temps je sais
que l'europe puisque c'est à ce niveau
là sans doute que les débats des
migrations doivent être menées doit se
doter de mécanismes efficaces de
surveillance de nos frontières
c'est le but du règlement évaluation qui
a donné lieu à un débat de principe avec
le parlement européen j'ai discuté de
cette question avec le président soultz
et de nombreux parlementaires européens
mais aussi avec la commissaire maelström
je veux dire que les solutions que j'ai
proposées ou de la france qui
aboutissent à renforcer le rôle de la
commission dans le processus
d'évaluation et la bonne prise en compte
des demandes du parlement européen
demande d'ailleurs de tous les groupes
dans le règlement d'évaluation semble
satisfaire aussi bien la commissaire que
le parlement européen
je sais bien enfin qu ici nous sommes
dans un lieu où les questions se posent
avec mesurée et nuancée ce que réclament
nos compatriotes je connais la
préoccupation permanente qui est la
vôtre pour le respect des principes
principes humanistes de droit et des
libertés publiques et l'exigence qui
anime et vauban sur des sujets sensibles
comme la loi pénitentiaire ou récemment
le fichier accompagnant la carte
d'identité en est ce souci cette
exigence
en sont des exemples parfaits je connais
aussi la liberté des sénateurs qui peut
les amener en conscience à penser
différemment dans leur propre camp votre
esprit en tout cas de tempérance
d'apaisement sera utile pour aborder les
sujets qui en dehors de ses murs et ses
sujets notamment sont toujours soumis
aux polémiques stériles aux
instrumentalisation et au fracas qui ne
font pas avancer le débat les questions
d'immigration d'intégration d'asile et
de nationalités ont en effet depuis de
nombreuses années alimenté les tensions
et par un drôle d'ailleurs de
renversement dans notre pays terre dont
l'histoire a affirmé sa tradition
d'accueil l'arrivant a été perçu comme
une menace et non plus comme une chance
jamais peut-être auparavant les mots de
jacques prévert parlant de ces étranges
étrangers n'avaient aussi bien décrit la
dureté d'un débat public
la volonté du président de la république
et du premier ministre est d'aller vers
l'apaisement
il m'appartient sans naïveté que les
quelles sont les règles du débat public
il m'appartient cependant dans mes
fonctions de mettre en oeuvre ces de
volonté à laquelle j'espère les français
souscrivent largement ministre de
l'intérieur j'ai la charge la sécurité
de nos concitoyens et j'assume
pleinement la fermeté nécessaires à
l'accomplissement d'une telle mission
je suis également le ministre de l'état
central ou des concentrés à travers son
réseau de préfecture et des
sous-préfectures et il m'appartient de
garantir la plénitude et la continuité
de l'action et je sais d'ailleurs tous
l'importance que vous sénateurs accordé
aussi à ces questions je suis le
ministre d'un état qui doit accueillir à
l'intérieur de son espace national de
ses frontières en fixant pour cela des
règles et en les faisant appliquer et le
ministre de l'intérieur et je veux le
souligner avec force ici est aussi celui
des grandes libertés publiques
c'est cet exemple cohérent formé à la
fois
formée d'un état à la fois régulateur
des flux migratoires est garant des
libertés publiques est fondamental qui
doit permettre au ministre que je suis
de mettre en oeuvre en lien étroit bien
évidemment avec les autres ministères
compétents une politique visant la
justice et l' équilibre en matière
d'immigration et d'intégration
cette politique s'appuiera sur deux
principes fondamentaux
l'objectivité et la transparence
plus largement il s'agit de mettre en
place des procédures juste de faire la
promotion d'un dialogue renouvelé avec
par exemple les associations les
organisations syndicales et de mener une
réflexion plus étroitement coordonnée
avec les collectivités territoriales
confronté comme l'état aux situations de
grande précarité que peuvent connaître
les migrants pour tendre vers davantage
de justice j'insiste des premières
avancées ont été réalisées elles doivent
se prolonger notamment par le biais d'un
travail législatif qui se traduira par
deux projets de loi l'un présenté à
l'automne blood probablement jeunes des
fleurs pas le travail gouvernemental ou
l'agenda l'autre au premier semestre
au cours de ces deux derniers mois nous
avons pris j'ai pris trois mesures à
caractère d'urgence
la première mesure prise avec mes
collègues michel sapin étudia fioraso
c'est l'abrogation de la circulaire du
31 mai 2011 sur les étudiants étrangers
il s'agissait là d'une mesure de bon
sens car cette circulaire conduisait à
refuser le droit au séjour à des
personnes hautement qualifiées et
souhaitant exercer leurs talents dans
notre pays
non là il en allait aussi de l'image de
la france est en vous quittant je me
rends au maroc où nous allons examiner
aussi évidemment ces questions qui sont
importantes pour des pays partenaires
deuxième mesure qui répond à
l'engagement du président de la
république
la circulaire du 6 juillet 2012 qui
place l'assignation à résidence comme
alternative à la rétention
administrative des familles qui doivent
être éloignés c'est désormais la règle
enfin la troisième mesure à la suite de
l'arrêt de la cour de justice de l'union
européenne en décembre 2011 qui n'avait
d'ailleurs donné lieu à aucune réaction
du précédent gouvernement il nous faut
je dis sans polémique d'ailleurs essayé
d'anticiper la jurisprudence européenne
sur ces questions puis en conséquent à
l'arrêt de la cour de cassation du 5
juillet dernier
il n'est plus procédé comme vous le
savez à des mises en garde à vue deux
ressortissants étrangers au seul motif
du séjour irrégulier sur le territoire
ceux ci demandent d'ailleurs une
évolution de notre droit qui
garantissent l'efficacité de l'action en
matière d'éloignement j'y reviendrai
parallèlement à ses premiers choix ses
premières mesures des travaux ont débuté
visant à doter notre administration d'un
cadre d'action clarifier et également
assoupli concernant certains points
essentiels admettre aux séjours
quelqu'un qui ne l'avait pas acquis le
droit
en d'autres termes le régulariser est un
acte important qui doit s'appuyer sur
des critères précis et objectifs
il s'agit là de donner une expression
concrète à notre devise républicaine et
à mettre un terme à toute idée de
partialité et d'arbitraire la république
celle inverse du privilège de l'
avantage et du traitement différencié a
priori la république c'est par tous et
pour chacun les mêmes principes du droit
qui s'applique
une circulaire est ainsi en cours de
préparation qui doit préciser les
critères de l'admission exceptionnelle
au séjour des critères qui vont être
discutés cet été avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes associations ou
syndicats
je le disais il ya un instant mais
évidemment je suis à l'écouté également
et c'est bien normal et c'est
l'essentiel des parlementaires des
critères qui se veulent compréhensible à
la fois où des personnes en situation
irrégulière
par celles qui nourrissent le projet de
venir sur notre territoire
tous les messages que nous faisons
passer tous ces pays sont un message
important il faut y veiller avec
prudence et puis aussi cela me paraît
essentiel à l'égard de nos compatriotes
ces critères portent sur les années de
présence sur le territoire les attaches
familiales
la scolarisation des enfants la
situation par rapport au travail donc
sur tout ce qui fait la réalité d'une
vie construite sur notre territoire
interprétée de manière trop restrictives
ces dernières années sans prendre
pleinement en compte la nature des liens
tissés par les demandeurs de titre avec
notre pays
ces critères demande tarification
réalisme en tout cas dans leurs
applications
il y avait trente mille régularisation
par an sous le précédent gouvernement
trente mille par an dont 15000 purement
discrétionnaire la clarification des
critères que j'appelle de mes voeux
permettra de réduire
je l'espère l'exercice n'est pas facile
la part d'incertitude qui pèse sur un
processus qui parfois jugé trop
discrétionnaire trop pin égales
d'ailleurs selon les préfectures donnera
ses biens son but de la lisibilité aux
citoyens aux gens et permettra de
résoudre les situations individuelles
les plus difficiles parfois d'ailleurs
il faut bien l'avouer le plus compliqué
mais je veux insister là dessus
elle n'a pas pour objet d'augmenter le
nombre de régularisations
les critères sont justes ils viseront à
sortir de toute logique d'arbitraire
mais ils resteront précis et rigoureux
je vous le disais à l'instant
vous serez prochainement amené à étudier
deux projets de loi visant à tendre vers
davantage de justice dans le projet de
loi présenté l'automne j'en dirai un mot
par ailleurs il sera également proposé
de mettre fin au délit de solidarité qui
permet de poursuivre l'aide
désintéressée apporté à les étrangers en
situation irrégulière sur la même base
juridique utilisé pour les filières
criminelles d'immigration
notre loi qui d'ailleurs a été peu
appliquée les
concernant je pense aux associations ou
même à des élus locaux c'est le cas dans
le nord pas de calais par exemple notre
loi ne serait punir ceux qui en toute
bonne foi veulent tendre une main ce
quoi la france ce n'est pas cela et on
cherche à traiter ces questions plutôt
par le dialogue
le second projet doit monsieur le
président présenté au premier semestre
2013 a évidemment mener un travail en
commun dans ses dispositions relatives à
l'immigration proposera la création d'un
titre de séjour pluriannuel pour les
étrangers en situation régulière sur
notre territoire
ceux ci doivent en effet bénéficier d'un
cadre administratif moins contraignant
difficulté obtenir le renouvellement
d'un titre de séjour sont des facteurs
de fragilisation économique des
stabilité et in fine et d'obstacles à
l'intégration
vous connaissez aussi la situation et je
veux y mettre fin
que les étrangers en situation régulière
l'occasion de la demande de titre de
séjour vivent dans un certain nombre de
nos préfectures
il s'agit donc par conséquent de sortir
d'une logique qui tout à la fois et du
revêtement complexifie les missions de
l'administration et se révèle au fond
contre-productive entre 50 à 60 mille
personnes en situation régulière
pourrait ainsi bénéficier de ce titre
pluri annuel je rappelle que ces
personnes bénéficient déjà d'un titre de
séjour dans ce même projet de loi
figurent a gelé voc un instant pardon
monsieur le président la question de
l'asile avec la transposition des
directives européennes qui vont être
adopté prochainement dans ce domaine la
france est une terre d'accueil mais
aussi de refuge en voulant parler un
jour nom de l'humanité toute entière le
patri acquis un statut singulier et
universel qui nous oblige un statut de
référence en matière de liberté pour
tous ceux et celles qui à travers le
monde subissent au quotidien
l'oppression et la violence l'asile
réclame cependant un cadre précis des
applications il ya ce titre une
réflexion est en cours avec nos
partenaires européens des partenaires
auprès de qui j'ai
insistez notamment dans le cadre du
conseil justice et affaires intérieures
de l'union sur la volonté de la france
de s'inscrire pleinement dans une
tradition et ce paquet asile va nous
amener à remettre à plat les procédures
applicables et je veux m'appuyer sur le
parlement pour garantir efficacement les
nouveaux droits accordés aux demandeurs
en préservant l'objectif de réduction
des délais fixés par le président de la
république vous avez raison
l'asile ce n'est pas une variable
d'ajustement de la politique
d'immigration
j'évoquais le sens de la mesure qui
caractérise votre assemblée et en
matière d'immigration faire preuve de
mesure c'est faire preuve de réalisme
elle réalise qu est la condition
nécessaire pour qu'un principe de
justice soient pérennes
le réalisme en matière d'immigration
c'est avant tout la prise en compte de
la situation économique et sociale de
notre pays
je sais que cela peut faire débat mais
je veux le dire dans les moments que vit
notre pays nous devons en tous cas nous
poser cette question dans cette logique
et conformément aux engagements du
président de la république
un débat sera organisé chaque année au
parlement sur la régulation des
migrations économiques en fonction aussi
des besoins de notre pays donc en lien
avec les partenaires sociaux
je ne veux pas oublier dans cette
discussion les collectivités
territoriales et les associations
le réalisme c'est également presque pu
commencer par là avoir parfaitement
conscience des filières d'immigration
clandestine et les combattre avec la
plus grande fermeté et je veux le dire
avec force ceux qui exploitent la misère
humaine doivent être combattue avec la
plus grande détermination
ce qui implique un redéploiement des
forces de sécurité un travail de fond
nécessaires au démantèlement des
filières en lien étroit aussi avec les
ministères du travail et du budget le
réalisme c'est aussi agir de manière
efficace en matière d'éloignement
il faut dire les choses simplement les
personnes en situation irrégulière sur
notre territoire et qui n'ont pas
vocation est resté doivent regagner leur
pays d'origine
la décision de la cour de cassation du 5
juillet
qui ne donne plus légalement le temps
matériel nécessaire pour examiner la
situation d'un étranger au regard de son
droit au séjour et d'en tirer les
conséquences administratives ouvre un
vide juridique il s'agit de combler il y
va de l'efficacité de la politique
d'éloignement qui je le redis est une
nécessité dans le cadre du projet de loi
présenté à l'automne que j'évoquais lien
instant un dispositif sera proposée qui
respectera les impératifs
constitutionnels et européens et
garantira un équilibre indispensable
entre le respect des libertés
individuelles et l'exigence de maîtrise
des flux migratoires
le réalisme c'est enfin comprendre la
question de l'immigration et de
l'intégration dans la diversité de leur
implication
ce qui signifie faire la promotion d'un
travail interministériel qui a été
parfois trop souvent oublié certains
sujets demande d'avancer en parfaite
coordination mais intelligence ce fut le
cas récemment avec l'envoi conjoint ce
qui représente peut être une première
dans ce domaine là d'une circulaire du
ministère de l'intérieur aux préfets et
d'une circulaire de la chancellerie au
procureur à la suite de la décision de
la cour de cassation
mettant fin aux gardes à vue au seul
motif donc du séjour irrégulier
de même les critères d'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour sont l'objet
d'une réflexion commune avec les
ministères du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
la consultation des acteurs sociaux qui
commencent cette semaine est ainsi menée
conjointement par mes équipes et celles
de michel sapin autre exemple le sujet
particulièrement délicat des étrangers
malades qui réclame une action commune
avec le ministère des affaires sociales
et de la santé afin d'améliorer
notamment dans le cadre des procédures
d'éloignement l'articulation entre les
agences régionales de santé et les
préfectures
on ne naît pas forcément français on
peut si on le souhaite
le devenir c'est d'ailleurs ce que je
fais il y a moins de 30 ans l'aude
nation n'a pas une identité figée dans
le marbre
elle est la somme d'identités multiples
mais qui se retrouve dans un idéal
commun et dans les lois communes qui
forment ce qu'est notre république
le défi de l'immigration je vous livre
une conviction sera relevé si la
naturalisation n'est plus vécue ou perçu
comme la fin d'un parcours du combattant
mais comme l'issue d'un processus
d'intégration qui a évidemment sa part
d'exigences
le nombre de naturalisations est en
chute libre
si rien n'est fait ce nombre va chuter
de 40% entre 2011 et 2012 après une
chute de 30 % entre 2010 et 2011
cette chute résulte d'une politique
délibérée des klur de la nationalité des
gens méritants et ne pose aucune
difficulté
je m'apprête à revenir sur les critères
introduit de manière peu connu par mon
prédécesseur
je veux faire de la nationalité un
moteur d'intégration de l'intégration et
non le résultat d'une course d'obstacles
aléatoire et donc forcément
discriminante
en appliquant ces orientations cette
ligne que je viens de vous exposer
forcément on ne fait pas tout le monde
mais de ce fait j'ai la conviction
d'atteindre ce point d'équilibré que
j'évoquais en fait j'entends les
critiques
ce sont mes derniers mots pour ce propos
je les reçois ces critiques monte au
sein d'un certain nombre d'associations
j'entends les critiques qui me reproche
dans des termes parfois très peu nuancé
je les reçois évidemment beaucoup moins
d'être au duo vis-à-vis des étrangers
des critiques qui se mêle à d'autres
venus cette fois d'ailleurs par la voix
même d'ailleurs de mon prédécesseur qui
me reprochent
je cite d'être laxiste c'est difficile
d'être à la fois dur et laxiste mais
j'ai la faiblesse de croire que c'est
critique contradictoires sont les
conséquences précisément d'un point
d'équilibré que je recherche sur les
sujets dont nous allons parler
aujourd'hui
même si évidemment je ne prétends pas
comme on le prétend d'ailleurs sur ce
sujet comme sur d'autres détenir la
vérité ni rien de parfait rien de figé
et la seule question qui doit nous
animer la suivante est ce que le choix
qui est fait est juste ou non s'il est
juste il sera appliqué
s'il est injuste il sera rejeté voilà
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
quelques-uns de ces éléments j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion de m'exprimer
le publiquement mais je suis conscient
qu'aujourd'hui nous pouvons approfondir
un certain nombre de sujets tout à fait
essentiel du grand merci bien merci
manuel valls monsieur le ministre pour
cet exposé liminaire par lequel vous
avez bien voulu faire un certain nombre
d' annonces sur des sujets auxquels nous
sommes très attentifs en particulier la
place de la loi dans le dispositif
vous avez bien voulu dire que le sénat
était attaché à la mesure vous savez
nous sommes aussi très attaché aux
libertés aux libertés publiques aux
droits de l'homme au fait que la france
est une terre d'accueil
de par son histoire mais nous sommes
tout autant attaché à ce qu'il y ait une
maîtrise de l'immigration maîtrise qu'il
convient de bien mettre en oeuvre vous
l'avez d'ailleurs souligné est notre
question serait s'il était possible
d'éviter un certain nombre de polémiques
trop facile
la question n'est en effet pas de savoir
si c'est trop laxistes ou si c'est trop
dur
la question est de savoir ce qui est
juste
la question est de savoir quel est le
droit et quel droit nouveau nous pouvons
fonder étant donné que vous avez
indiquée c'était d'ailleurs les
engagements du président de la
république un certain nombre
d'orientations
qui peut naturellement constitue une
politique différente de celle qui a été
mise en oeuvre par cette loi
pas moi en cinq ans pas moi sur
l'immigration est aussi d'ailleurs le
droit d'asile dont nous avons pu
débattre dans cette assemblée
alors nous sommes nombreux et beaucoup
de collègues sont venus de toutes les
commissions
1 c'est dire que le sujet intéresse
qu'il me soit permis de vous dire je ne
vais pas parler de manière et errer sans
pour autant suivre le fils de monsieur
le président de la commission des
finances
hier mais je dirais que un bon nombre
d'entre nous ont sans doute perçue
favorablement tout cas j'en suis la
circulaire sur les étudiants monsieur le
ministre
parce que c'était tellement pénible de
voir tous ces étudiants du monde qui
venait frapper à la porte de la france
et qu'ils se trouvent et rejeté ou alors
contraint à faire des queues de auprès
de bureaux et aller ailleurs
c'est aussi très important pour le
rayonnement de la france que
d'accueillir les jeunes étudiants du
monde
d'autre part aussi la circulaire
monsieur le ministre sur la place des
enfants ou plutôt la non place ou
l'absence de place des enfants au sein
des centres de rétention
vous avez annoncé que vous comptiez nous
proposer de mettre fin au délit de
solidarité
c'est vrai que ce délit nous l'avons
souvent pour un certain nombre d'entre
nous d'ailleurs de toute orientation
politique
il nous est arrivé de parler contre ce
délit je me permets de dire parce que
c'est vrai puis ce qui revenait à
pénaliser un certain nombre
d'associations qui faisait tout
simplement mission humanitaire e par
rapport à eux
à la question ed circulaire que j'ai
cités une première question qui apparaît
est la suivante on ne peut sans doute
pas s'en tenir aux circulaires dont
il faut sans doute qu'un certain nombre
de dispositions soient dans la loi et
quand je dis sans doute je pourrais dire
certainement même si certainement sur le
plan de la linguistique est aussi
hypothétique que sans doute ce qui
d'ailleurs un autre sujet e
deuxièmement par rapport aux questions
du regroupement familial
nous sommes un certain nombre à penser
receipts me semble-t-il que l'ensemble
des clauses qui ont été fixés et inscrit
dans la loi aboutissent ressources
passage ressources exigées passage de 12
à 18 mois de la durée de séjour
nécessaire pour pouvoir demander le
regroupement familial
obligation pour le conjoint de d'obtenir
un visa de long séjour durcissement de
la condition du logement et cetera et
cetera
tout cela aboutit quand même à de
grandes difficultés pour le regroupement
familial est tout simplement pour le
droit de vivre avec son conjoint sans
compter les questions des examens à
caractère culturel et linguistique
je sais que ceci naturellement on
peuvent avoir une pertinence mais songez
à ce qu'il adviendrait si l'on imposé
aux conjoints de tel ou tel le français
allant travailler en chine ou en inde ou
en d'autres pays de connaître sur le
plan linguistique sur le plan des moeurs
et de la culture ce qu'on demande
s'agissant de la république française
dont là il ya des sujets par rapport
auquel nous serions intéressés de
connaître vos orientations de même en
matière de naturalisations là vous avez
j'avais posé la question mais vous avez
déjà répondu parce que c'est vrai qu'une
politique nouvelle de naturalisation
peut être une réponse un certain nombre
de difficultés de la politique
d'immigration enfin il ya la crise il ya
la question excusez moi de l'éloignement
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
vous savez combien
quels sons qu'elle est quelles sont vos
ambitions la matière merci merci à
madame à ça si monsieur jeannerot merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais d'abord saluer
votre décision juste et conforme par
ailleurs aux orientations européennes
d'avoir mis fin pour les familles ou à
leur situation à leur admission en
centre de rétention
cette décision née
sur la situation catastrophique due à
l'insuffisance de places dans les
centres d'hébergement d'urgence et qui
se trouve du coup encore un peu plus
aggravée par cette juste décision
donc je souhaiterais vraiment que nous
puissions regarder notamment dans la
perspective de l'hiver qui sera là dans
quelques mois
comment nous allons aborder cette
situation par ailleurs je crois que ça a
été un peu évoqué tout à l'heure j'ai
entendu une notion par rapport à
laquelle je souhaiterais avoir des
éclairages qui a été avancé par les
services de la préfecture
s'agissant d'étrangers dont on me disait
qu'il n'était ni expulsables ni
régularisables alors je voudrais savoir
comment faisons-nous par rapport à ce
type de population pour apporter
précisément la bonne réponse
merci monsieur de votre
intervention
et je vous rejoins sur un point qui est
celui de la régularisation j'allais dire
de ce tir cullers des étrangers des
étudiants étrangers qui effectivement me
paraît souhaitable d'accueillir ces
étudiants dans la mesure où ce sont de
vrais étudiants parce que ils seront des
ambassadeurs demain dans le monde entier
et donc je trouve cette mesure
intéressante pour le reste pour le reste
j'ai trois questions à vous poser la
première c'est sur la régularisation
vous avez parlé de critères objectifs on
peut être d'accord sur le fond
effectivement vous avez cité le nombre
d'années le travail la situation
familiale
mais alors une question qui revient
souvent
quid des personnes un des critères quid
des personnes qui auront eu maille avec
la justice ou la police pour être ou pas
régularisée c'est un élément important
de la régularisation et je souhaiterais
qu'on en tienne compte
deuxième point deuxième question
reconduite à la frontière on l'a vu
c'est plus facile à dire qu'à faire
et tout à l'heure notre collègue de
mayotte nous parler de 40% de réitère
donc dans ce domaine
qu'entendez vous qu'est ce que vous
pensez faire pour être selon votre
formule efficace et donc ne pas avoir
autant de réitérant et avoir des
reconduites à la frontière troisième
question et dernière question en tirez
vous c'est le ministre sur le
regroupement familial
il y avait des critères que vous estimez
monsieur le président de la commission
semble-t-il trop stricte
vous avez cité un exemple que je
qualifierais je vous respecte mais d'un
peu spécieux celui de france et en chine
et cédera à ma connaissance et je dis
bien ma connaissance je ne savais pas
que les chinois étaient inquiets d'une
immigration française par contre les
français
le problème de l'immigration se pose
incontestablement alors personnellement
ça ne me paraît pas trop strict si on
veut réussir comme l'a dit monsieur le
ministre
une vraie intégration minerai à ce
moment là est ce qu'il est excessive de
demander qu'il y ait un logement décent
je suis maire monsieur le président la
commission
j'ai reçu quelqu'un qui est venu me voir
en me disant voilà j'ai un studio de 30
mètres carrés et nous sommes 5
il est rentré lui et ensuite il a fait
venir son épouse et les trois enfants
qu'est ce que je réponds à ça donc
est-ce qu'il est excessif de demander un
logement décent et je rappelle que par
ailleurs une mannequin millions de
logements en france
deuxièmement d'avoir aidé d'être assuré
qu'il ya un vrai travail parce que sinon
ça sera de l'assistanat et je rappelle
de ce côté là qui à 3 4 millions de
chômeurs donc les mesures plein de bons
sentiments voir l'angélisme sont
sympathiques mais cantonné sur le
terrain on n'a pas du tout ça non non
non j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit les mesures
monsieur leurs joues me connaît très
bien et si je ne suis pas angélique vous
avez le droit de penser monsieur
c'était dans l'absolu je rappelle tout
simplement aux politiques que vous êtes
tous autour de la table que
l'immigration incontrôlée
je revienne suède bon une immigration
incontrôlée en europe a conduit sherco
le poussée populiste dans la
quasi-totalité des pays d'europe et ça
ça me paraît être ça me paraît être un
élément très important de ce que nous
devons faire penser réfléchir sans doute
au moins autant que le coût pour lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine
merci monsieur monsieur le compte
pour cet échange je vais essayer de
poser mes questions de manière assez
télégraphique
vous avez évoqué la question des
naturalisations
on arrive à des critères qui sont tout à
fait aberrant puisque once de haut doit
constater que des gens qui ont
l'équivalent du baccalauréat aujourd'hui
de français ou le bac vous passerez le
bac français l'étranger ne dans les
établissements français et étrangers ne
remplissent pas les ne remplissent pas
les conditions de naturalisation donc
par rapport à ce qui a été évoqué il ya
un vrai problème de critères aujourd'hui
de difficultés des critères sur la
question de la politique d'asile j'aurai
deux sujets ya si on veut réduire les
délais de d'asile il ya deux questions
l'accès aux préfectures et les moyens de
l'ofpra dont la plupart des officiers de
protection sont aujourd'hui précarisés
il ya vraiment un effort à faire de ce
côté là deuxièmement en termes de
politiques liées aux procédures
prioritaires et donc à l'effet non
suspensif d'une décision de l'ofpra il
ya eu une décision de la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme est ce que vous
allez modifier les principes de ce
recours nous de ces procédures
prioritaires concernant le droit au
séjour et les visas
je me réjouis à l'entente du de la
suppression de la circulaire du 31 mai
sur en particulier un programme de plus
de cent mille étudiants brésiliens pour
lequel un certain nombre de nos
partenaires dont l'allemagne
on souhaitait supprimer complètement les
visas est ce que vous envisagez de faire
la même chose pour les étudiants
brésiliens de ce grand programme de cent
mille étudiants pour lequel la france
devrait d'accueillir autour de dix mille
étudiants mais on est en compétition
avec d'autres pays qui supprime les
visas est ce que il est possible pour ce
programme de les supprimer deuxième
deuxième question les associations qui
travaillent sur les sur les roms et les
ressortissants roumains et bulgares qui
est ressortissant roumain bulgare qui
qui qui qui qui viennent en france
tous les efforts sont jeunes d'une
certaine manière quasi inutile contenu
des mesures transitoires qui aujourd'hui
empêche ces gens de bénéficier des
droits des citoyens européens de droit
au travail droit donc à sortir de la
précarité est ce que vous envisagez une
évaluation aujourd'hui des mesures
transitoires pour éventuellement les
supprimer assez rapidement de manière à
ce que au moins ceux qui trouveraient un
travail puisse être sortir de la
précarité
enfin troisième question y aller un
certain nombre de taxes sur les cartes
de séjour qui avait été largement
augmenté lors le projet de loi de
finances 2012
est ce que vous soutiendriez l'idée de
les remettre à un niveau acceptable et
supportable pour les étrangers merci
monsieur le comte monsieur portelli oui
monsieur le ministre d'abord voulais
vous remercier à mon tour en tant
qu'universitaire pour la pour avoir
abrogé le décret sur les étudiants
étrangers
vous voulez vous dire de mon expérience
qu'il faudra plus qu'un abrogation pour
rétablir le flux d'étudiants de valeur
vers notre pays je dirige moi même un
master 2 dans ma faculté
je peux vous dire que nous avons presque
plus d'étudiants des états francophones
absolument incroyable quand on regarde
les pays du maghreb ou d'afrique
subsaharienne bien le nombre d'étudiants
a diminué d'à peu près 80 % en l'espace
d'une dizaine d'années donc voilà je
voulais
le signaler j'avais en fait de questions
qu'ils posent qui portent sur des
problèmes de discrimination qui à mon
avis sont assez graves
le premier concerne un sujet dont vous
parlez bien sûr c'est celui des
régularisations
j'ai pas mal de cas de personnes qui
donc qui demande à être régularisés
qu'on aide à être régularisés qui trouve
un contrat de travail puisque ce qu'on
leur demande
sauf qu'ensuite le barrage tombe c'est
que il ya une taxe qui est exigé par
l'employeur qui s'engagent à recruter la
personne qui est une taxe qui équivaut à
peu près à un mois de salaire au smic
bon et je peux vous dire que dans un cas
sur deux l'employeur s'arrête parce que
tout simplement il veut bien recruter la
personne en question mais il ne veut pas
payer la taxe à mon humble avis cette
taxe elle est totalement contraire aux
conventions de l'oit et est même allé je
crois même contrainte tout simplement à
la constitution parce qu'elle crée une
inégalité entre les candidats à un
contrat de travail
donc ça c'est un point pour moi qui est
extrêmement grave
je pense que donc qu'il est vraiment
qu'il doit être réglée d'urgence la
deuxième question vous y avait fait
allusion tout à l'heure c'est le
problème de l'examen culturel entre
guillemets linguistique qu'on fait
passer aux candidats à la naturalisation
moi je peux vous dire que dans ma
commune je parle de ma commune j'ai des
ressortissants qui sont dans la commune
depuis parfois trente ans ou plus qui
sont arrivés analphabètes et qui le sont
assez lorsque tout simplement les
conditions de travail familial ça on
fait qu' ils n'ont pas pu n'ont pas eu
le temps ou n'ont pas osé accéder à des
études scolaires même de base et pour
ces gens là bien l'idée de passer un
examen est un vrai traumatisme et
et pourtant ils ne sont pas ils
n'arrivent pas ils sont là depuis des
années et personnellement j'ai toujours
vécu cette candide cette clause comme
quelque chose d'assez ces pros c'est
scandaleux ça me rappelle les clauses
que l'on mettait dans les états du sud
des états unis au lendemain de la guerre
de sécession qui ont fait que pendant un
an
les anciens esclaves et leurs
descendants n'ont pas pu voter parce
qu'on a introduit des clauses comme
celle là pour avoir le droit de
s'inscrire sur les listes électorales
merci merci monsieur portelli monsieur
faure cassin tout d'abord je vais
essayer de répondre aux injonctions de
concision laquelle vous avez fait appel
pour vous dire que j'ai pas de question
particulière à signaler en tant que
sénateur de base mais je tiens à faire
part de leurs réactions
d'abord vous dire monsieur le ministre
que j'ai particulièrement apprécié la
clarté de votre discours sans langue de
bois ça nous change beaucoup de
certaines attitudes
ensuite il faut dire que ce mélange de
rigueur et de fermeté et en même temps
d'humanisme et de générosité me convient
parfaitement
et il ya quelque chose que j'ai noté
c'est que lorsque vous avez dit qu'il
fallait abandonner les principes
discrétionnaire pour faire place à la
justice et à la transparence
j'approuve très nettement ce point de
vue car chaque fois qu'on a les
principes discrétionnaire c'est la
république qui est abîmée chaque fois
qu'on fait appel à la justice et la
transparence c'est la république qui
force qui sont renforcés et le rôle d'un
ministre de l'intérieur c'est surtout de
renforcer les principes républicains et
je vous ferai part de la réaction des
forces sécurité lors de votre bref
passage dans le département des hautes
pyrénées
ils ont considérablement apprécié votre
discours et surtout la considération que
vous avez pour leur travail
merci monsieur fortassin madame benbassa
pour ceux qui militent dans le secteur
de l'immigration je voulais vous
rappeler que le gouvernement a décidé
dans le décret relative aux attributions
de votre ministère de garde et
l'intégration et l'immigration dans les
prérogatives bien sûr de votre ministère
comme vous le savez mieux que moi ce
rattachement date de 2010 et il est
emblématique de la réforme engagée par
le gouvernement sarkozy largement
critiquées par la gauche et les
associations oeuvrant en matière des
droits des étrangers
on aurait pu penser que la gauche
arriver au pouvoir
on les détacher la question de
l'intégration du ministère de
l'intérieur pour marquer une rupture
symbolique avec la politique sarkozy en
matière d'immigration
merci madame benbassa je pense que va
compris que votre intervention était
achevée et très bien je bien compris
alors oui oui ce jeu j'ai été trés j'ai
remarqué alors madame tasca
monsieur le ministre pour votre
introduction qui nous ouvre j'ai envie
de dire enfin des perspectives positive
constructive sur la politique
d'immigration dans dans ce pays j'ai
noté beaucoup d'annoncés qui me
paraissent extrêmement positive je
souhaite que vous ayez les moyens de les
mettre tout en oeuvre pour ma part comme
ma collègue vient de l'évoquer je veux
dire que il me semble au contraire
positif de joindre la responsabilité de
l'immigration et celle de l'intégration
même si en ce qui concerne l'intégration
vous êtes évidemment appelé à travailler
avec l'ensemble de vos collègues au
gouvernement mais je pense qu'on ne peut
pas avoir un discours juste sur
l'immigration si on ne se donne pas les
moyens d'une politique d'intégration
tout à fait active
vous avez évoqué très brièvement votre
le dernier conseil européen et la
question de
l'espace schengen est ce que vous
pourriez revenir un petit peu je tiens à
vous dire qu'il n'y a eu aucun procès
d'intention à votre égard sur la
position que vous avez été amené à
prendre
nous avons d'ailleurs déjà rencontré des
certains de vos collaborateurs sur ce
sujet mais ici aussi bien la commission
des lois que la commission des affaires
européennes se sont préoccupés de
solliciter ce qui s'était dit là donc
moi j'aimerais que vous nous donniez
votre appréciation personnelle sur
l'état d'esprit de vos collègues au sein
de l'union par rapport à aux évaluations
schengen et par rapport à ces fameuses
circonstances exceptionnelles qui
pourrait permettre le rétablissement de
contrôles intérieurs mais encore une
fois monsieur le ministre il n'y avait
aucun procès d'intention ce qui concerne
votre position mais un vrai souci sur ce
que peut devenir la politique européenne
d'autant que nous constatons que dans un
certain nombre de d'état membres la
question des migrations n'ai pas regardé
comme elle l'est dans notre pays tous
les états membres ne sont pas des terres
d'accueil naturel et et même au
contraire
merci madame tasca monsieur béchu merci
monsieur le président monsieur oui je
suis extrêmement gêné parce que un
impératif et que j'aurai pas le vrai
semblant pas moi non plus le temps
d'entendre votre réponse mais comme j'ai
cru comprendre que vous aviez vous même
des impératifs peut-être que vous ne
répondrez à personne ce qui diminuerait
ma gêne
et voit un excellent compte rendu je
souhaiterais en 4 ou voyant prendre
trois points très rapide non pas engager
un débat large sur ces questions dont
chacun mesure qu'elles sont complexes et
que les déclarations d'intention sont
une chose la manière de mettre en oeuvre
et de tenir une ligne de crête entre
fermeté et humanisme se fait au fur et à
mesure d'un exercice ministériel qui
commence j'aimerais dans la continuité
des propos du de mon collègue jeannerot
vous dire que une des questions qui se
posent pour les chrs ce sont les
profondes inégalités territoriales dans
notre pays sur le nombre de personnes
accueillies territoire par territoire
il ya une question globale en france et
puis ensuite dans certains territoires
parfois parce que les collectivités
parfois parce que les associations
étaient actives un nombre de personnes
accueillies qui finit par poser des
difficultés au regard de la population
le maine-et-loire accueille plus de
personnes en situation de demande
d'asile que la loire atlantique alors
que chacun sait que en termes de
population on est pourtant dans des
situations très différentes
une des explications c'est que partout
vous avez en france une borne eurodac
vous avez un nombre important de
demandeurs et il ya deux solutions
celle que la généralisation des bornes
dornach dans les préfectures pour faire
en sorte d'avoir un moyen partout de
pouvoir avoir ce type de mesure et
éviter qu'ils aient des complexités
administratives en fonction des
territoires et un second qui consiste à
défendre un principe de régionalisation
strictes pour éviter d'avoir des écarts
avec des territoires qui sont pas les
plus grands se retrouvent avec des
populations plus importante je tranche
pas je dis juste que ça ça fait partie
des soucis je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
distinguer les questions d'immigration
de régularisation de sans-papiers sans
les connecter à l'asile pour une raison
très simple c'est que c'est la longueur
des procédures d'examen des demandes
d'asile qui amène des gens est dans une
situation de nini objectif si nous
étions en situation au bout de quelques
mois de dire à quelqu'un vous êtes le
bienvenu ou vous n'êtes pas le bienvenu
le fait de le raccompagner à la
frontière serait autrement plus simple
que quand on attend 18 ou 24 mois et qui
à ce moment là des liens humains qui se
sont tissés et si on ne s'aperçoit pas
que la demande d'asile est le moyen le
plus simple de pouvoir rentrer en france
pour ensuite introduire un certain
nombre de procédures
on manque une étape dans la
compréhension globale du phénomène donc
moi je pense que on ne peut pas
distinguer les deux et que le
renforcement des moyens pour l'examen de
la demande d'asile est à la fois
nécessité par la conception que nous
avons de la mission de notre pays et de
la dignité qui va avec l'accueil mais
les nécessaires pour conduire une
politique de fermeté avec des
régularisations qui soit compréhensible
par les populations en évitant qu'on est
des situations qui au fil du temps
finissent par devenir de fait des
régularisations
enfin il ya la question de la m e du
droit de timbre
on a évoqué cet après-midi le principe
des taxes on a évoqué le principe des
étudiants étrangers qui bénéficient
quand ils arrivent en france des apl et
moi je considère que sur cette question
c'est pas la nationalité qui doit fonder
le principe du versement ou pas d'un
timbre mais c'est un minimum d'examen
sur la question des ressources pour
parler de la situation par exemple des
étudiants en situation étrangères qui
touche les appels plein pot compte tenu
du fait que leurs parents ne travaillant
pas en france ne déclare rien quand bien
même ils auraient des situations sur le
plan financier extrêmement intéressante
à l'étranger pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux qui envoient leurs enfants
apprendre le français dans notre pays il
ya une profonde injustice
non pas en raison de la nationalité mais
en raison tout simplement des
différentiels de ressources qui ne sont
pas pris en compte
merci monsieur béchu madame qui a ri
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre puisque l'occasion m'est donnée
je voudrais vous dire à quel point j'ai
apprécié vos propos lors de votre prise
de fonction
quand vous avez déclaré d'une phrase no
stigmatiseront aucune communauté
parce que la confiance à la république
se fonde aussi sur des propos apaisants
elle se fonde sur et elle passe par
l'égalité de traitement aussi est
illégal trait d'égalité de traitement se
fonde sur des critères simples
intelligible par tout ce que ce soit
aussi bien pour la régularisation des
sans papiers que pour évidemment l'accès
à la nationalité
alors je sens bien votre volonté de
mettre en oeuvre une égalité de
traitement
et comment cette uniformité sur
l'ensemble du territoire sera telle mise
en oeuvre alors qu'il y a de si
mauvaises habitudes prises et depuis si
longtemps je voulais aussi évoqué la
question des taxes qui pèsent sur les
familles notamment quand il s'agit des
taxes pour le droit au séjour ça a été
évoqué par mon collègue le compte dans
le cas d'une famille ces taxes peuvent
aller jusqu'à peuvent atteindre 1500 à
2000 euros
donc c'est quand même énorme et il
faudrait quand même qu'on se penche sur
sur ces montants est sûre les étudiants
étrangers je voudrais quand même dire
parce que je viens d'entendre collègues
s'exprimer sur cette question que je me
réjouis de voir que certains aujourd'hui
trouve du bien-fondé à la résolution que
j'ai eu l'honneur de porter ici sur les
étudiants étrangers et qui a abouti à
l'abrogation la circulaire dans la
circulaire guéant
en fait quand même j'aurais préféré ce
soutien en séance et je tenais à le dire
bien merci madame qui a ri monsieur
hérisson merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
mon intervention départ véritablement
directement liés ni sur le plan
législatif et réglementaire à
l'immigration mais dans l'esprit de nos
concitoyens
tout le monde le sait ici
la problématique des gens du voyage dont
je m'occupe depuis un certain nombre
d'années avec l' amalgame qui a été
créée que la présence des roms dans
notre territoire vont que la plupart de
nos concitoyens pensent qu'il s'agit
d'un problème d'immigration
raison de plus pour que nous ayons en
parler nous ayons à débattre et que nous
puissions à travers plusieurs
propositions de loi qui ont été déposées
et une ppl que je déposerai à l'issue de
deux missions consécutives de 6 mois qui
m'ont été confiées au cours des années
précédentes mais je ne déposerai pas
moins de 1100 vous avoir adressé un
exemplaire du projet et après l'avoir
rapprocher dans une discussion avec le
défenseur des droits parce que je crois
qu'il y à là il y avait là la nécessité
de faire ce que je voulais dire sur ce
point c'est que nous avons véritablement
besoin de traiter de ce sujet et j'ai le
président de la commission des lois je
pense que dès lors que j'aurais déposé
cette ppl je compte sur vous pour que
nous puissions continuer avec je le
dirai le même esprit puisque j'ai à
m'occuper de ce problème là depuis
l'époque où j'étais en tandem tous les
deux vice présidents de l'association
des maires de france dans les années 95
2000 avec louis besson à l'époque maire
de chambéry
parce que c'est le principe de
fonctionnement l'association des maires
de france
on met toujours deux parlementaires de
la majorité et de l'opposition sur un
sujet aussi sensible que celui là et que
j'appelle de mes voeux à ce que le
rapporteur de ce texte ou un moment vu
quelqu'un de la majorité du sénat de
manière à ce que nous puissions faire le
pendant sur cette proposition qui par
rapport à d'autres al'avantage non pas
parce que c'est moi mais parce que à la
suite des deux vireux des deux missions
j'ai pu rassembler l'essentiel des
points urgents à traiter sur la
problématique des gens du voyage je
crois qu'il ya là un problème d'autant
que même s'il s'agisse pas d'un problème
d'immigration
aujourd'hui dans la période transitoire
même c'est un peu technique la bulgarie
et plus particulièrement la roumanie
sont dans une situation où effectivement
le sujet
et traiter de leur présence sur le
territoire avec les textes concernant
l'immigration
mais ce dispositif prend fin le 31
décembre 2013 nous aurons donc à partir
de 2014 à traiter les gens du voyage de
l'union européenne oruma compris il
rappelle que la roumanie est le pays qui
à lui tout seul à une minorité ethnique
de deux millions huit cent mille
habitants qui sont des roms qui sont
pour moi tu as fait de l'avis des
roumaines mais qui sont des roms et sur
lequel il est nécessaire ou non
j'allais dire d'un principe de
prévention et d'anticipation de traiter
de ce sujet et si possible de le traiter
par la loi parce que à partir du moment
où ils appartiendront définitivement à
l'union européenne
ils auront droit au statut de gens du
voyage dans notre pays et c'est de là
que viennent la grande majorité de ces
personnes qui souhaitent vivre en france
qui sont aujourd'hui au nombre de quinze
mille mêler aux quatre formules gens du
voyage dans notre pays
dans un amalgame assez difficile à gérer
et sur lequel nous avons besoin de
travailler ensemble je vous redis ici
donc j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de vous le
dire mon entière disposition sur un
sujet sur lequel je travaille depuis
1995 et pour lequel j'ai été un des deux
rapporteurs de la loi besson en 2000
merci monsieur hérisson nous savons
votre implication et soyez sûrs que la
commission des lois très de huy traitera
avec beaucoup de soin votre votre propre
proposition
mes chers collègues voilà le dilemme
devant lequel nous sommes monsieur
ministre veut reprendre son avion il
serait bien qu'il put répondre à vos
questions et j'ai encore quatre orateurs
inscrits alors je vous propose de
demander aux quatre orateurs inscrits de
faire un effort exceptionnel pour que
monsieur le ministre puisse répondre
est-ce que vous en êtes d'accord alors
les quatre orateurs qui vont devoir
réussir cet exploit ce sont d'abord
virginie klès oui merci monsieur le
président j'ai donc être très brève dans
le prolongement tout d'abord de
l'intervention de monsieur béchu
outre la répartition territoriale des
personnes sur le territoire au sud
répartition des charges qui incombent
book
au département sur le territoire charge
via l'aide sociale et à l'aide à
l'enfance
donc est ce qu'il y aura une solidarité
nationale ou est-ce que l'état sera
coordonnateur de quelque chose qui
s'établira entre les collectivités mais
je crois que là il ya quelque chose à
réfléchir et ma deuxième question
portait sur les tests osseux pratiquée
pour déterminer l'âge des mineurs
supposées mineur sur le territoire quid
de ces tests osseux qui sont pas fiables
qui prennent du temps financier en
moyens matériels etc et qui sont
générateurs ou non générateurs de loin
derrière avec un résultat une fois plus
sur le plan scientifique très peu sûre
merci madame claisse eux monsieur van
dillen donc une alité française je vous
suggérerais bien qu'on ne sache qu'à
très court une mission inspection
générale de l'administration
les sénateurs que ça intéresse une
préfecture celle du nord et quand on
regarde concrètement comment on peut
améliorer le circuit
monsieur vandierendonck apprécierez de
faire partie de la mission
et en plus il est très compétent bien
monsieur buffet et danseuses ministre
une observation de questions la première
observation ses quenottes ya pas de
changement fondamental dans la politique
que voulait mener par rapport à la
précédente en particulier à l'égard des
reconduites à la frontière et de la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
et en particulier sur les principes de
régularisation sur ces principes de
régularisation vous avez évoqué la mise
en place de critères objectifs qui en
soi est une bonne chose
en revanche je voudrais savoir comme
quelles instructions vous allez donner
aux préfets qui reste quand même des
interlocuteurs privilégiés dans nos
différents départements sur ce type de
problématique et ils sont parce qu'ils
ont la souplesse d'appréciation
nécessaires des régulateurs importants
sur lesquels nous savons pouvoir compter
et ils ont besoin de liberté pour
pouvoir exercer ce rôle-là pouvez nous
confirmer
deuxième question ce qui concerne le
droit d'asile que je mets à part
évidemment nous savons tous que le du
raid 1
de la procédure et capitale puisque plus
la procédure est courte - nous risquons
les l'immigration irrégulière l usage de
cette procédure à des fins de maintien
sur le territoire et nous savons
particulièrement que c'est la cour
nationale du droit d'asile qui est la
plus chargée aujourd'hui
l'ofpra ayant globalement conserver ses
moyens avez vous prévu dans le budget
prochain les moyens budgétaires
suffisants pour permettre à la cour
nationale du droit d'asile de remplir sa
mission dans un délai le plus rapide
possible afin que l'instruction des
demandes se fasse dans un délai
objectifs fixés de l'ordre de une année
merci merci monsieur buffet madame
blonde à rejoindre celle de madame plaît
c'est de monsieur béchu à savoir les
difficultés qu'ont les préfectures de
pouvoir assumer l'hébergement des
demandeurs d'asile est particulièrement
lorsque les budgets affectés aux
préfectures ont été entièrement
consommée en mai on met jusqu'en mai
dernier et après quid justement de
l'hébergement de ces de ces personnes et
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir évidemment des
conventions entre les collectivités
territoriales les grandes villes et
l'état mais l'état n'a pas pu évidemment
assumer ses responsabilités entières à
partir de mai dernier
merci bien merci mais la bombe a eu
merci tous mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président est
évidemment
monsieur le président poncelet excusez
moi monsieur le président pense les vous
allez dire un mot peut-être
interventions précédentes il y aura très
rapidement un problème au niveau au
niveau des départements je suis
président de conseil général et
j'insiste sur deux points c'est que
d'une part on compte on confie opposé
généraux sur des missions sociales
importantes
hier pas important et on ne règle pas la
facture ondres et le pas la facture ne
serait ce que pour l'apa et est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
cependant les collectivités
territoriales ne peuvent presque plus
investir elle peut plus investir 73 % de
l'investissement en france et réalisé
par les collectivités territoriales si
le mal ne peuvent plus investir y aura
tarissement mais je voudrais simplement
moi vous demander un service
il ya un pays que je connais tout
particulièrement que j'apprécie beaucoup
et où je vais régulièrement avec ce pays
il ya eu des périodes froides c'est vrai
mais aujourd'hui j'ai constaté une
volonté très forte de ce pays de se
rapprocher de la france de vivre avec la
france le pas et ne serai pas surpris
c'est l'algérie et monsieur fabius il en
rentre qui pourra vous le dire
et par conséquent je voudrais que dans
vous consulat en ce qui concerne bien
sûr l'algérie beaucoup de jeunes
viennent vers le français beaucoup
veulent que l'est de la france venait en
france où sports d'hiver ici l appât
pour y rester mais pour connaître ce
pays donc que les conciles à que les
consulats depuis l'ipad n'est pas comme
ils le font pour d'autres pays et que je
peux comprendre mais là qu'on facilite
au contraire cette certes relations
entre ce pays cette jeunesse stationner
ce qui en a la volonté d'apprendre le
français
la volonté de venir en france ils
repartent chez eux après ils viennent
n'est ce pas il ya des liens très forts
qui se tissent mais parfois dans les
consulats excusez moi l'expression un
peu populaire on puis on pinaille on
pinaille et ça laisse aller dès que ça
les décourage alors j'assume à plusieurs
reprises intervenu personnellement
auprès des consulats vous demande mais
vouloir être mal interprété leur dire
concernant les jeux la jeunesse
algérienne qu'il lui reste bien sûr à
établir ces liens très forts d'amitié
merci merci monsieur le président pons
les monsieur le ministre
rapidement et je reviendrai évidemment
c'est ce que j'allais dire avant de
céder évidemment la parole
le président poncelet très rapidement on
aura l'occasion de devenir de revenir de
travailler avec vous avec les
rapporteurs
soyez en certain je vous réponds
d'ailleurs tout de suite monsieur le
président je me rendrai en algérie cet
automne avec la volonté pas seulement de
traiter ces sujets de sujets plus
délicats mais essayer de travailler sur
la problématique des visas et des
conventions très particulière que nous
avons avec l'algérie j'évoquerai aussi
ces questions mais dans un autre cadre
moins tendu peut-être sur ces
problématiques là dès demain dès ce soir
puisque j'y arrive au au maroc
très rapidement même s'il ya beaucoup de
sujets ils sont tous passionnants même
évidemment j'aurais aimé uniquement
retenir l'intervention du sénateur
françois fortassin mais comprendrait
n'était très agréable et je vous en
remercie
mais je ne peux pas uniquement me tenir
à celle ci mais je vous remercie
bien évidemment le débat sur le
périmètre du ministère
c'est un choix qui a été fait par le
présent la public et par le point je
comprends toutes ces questions et tous
ces débats mais j'essaye responsabilité
celle de l'immigration de l'intégration
du droit d'asile et je les assumerai la
seule chose que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il ya une cohérence été rappelé par
catherine tasca je la remercie et en
même temps ce que je veux dire tout
simplement c'est que ce grand ministère
de l'intérieur ne doit pas être
uniquement le ministère
de l'ordre public c'est évidemment très
important et sans ordre public il n'ya
pas de démocratie
mais c'est aussi celui de libertés
publiques et donc d'autres fois il y
avait aussi les collectivités
territoriales voire l'outre-mer encore
récemment ça n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui donc j'assume cette
responsabilité tous les débats
évidemment notamment conditionné par des
parlementaires sont estimables je peux
les comprendre et par exemple sur
l'asile et sur le fera j'ai une
responsabilité administrative et
financière
je n'ai en aucun cas le pouvoir de
mettre en cause l'indépendance
l'autonomie notamment des agents qui
travaillent à l'ofpra et de ce point de
vue là je réponds tout de suite
nous sommes dans la discussion de
préparation du projet de loi de finances
2013 avec j'obtiendrai les moyens
nécessaires pour accélérer effectivement
les processus
le président a public quand il était
candidat s'était engagé à réduire les
délais à six mois
c'est le bon chiffre pour faire face aux
problèmes qui ont été évoqués tout à
l'heure il est vrai et nous l'avons dit
avec le président sueur il n'y a pas un
lien entre immigration et asile parce
que l'asile c'est un droit régis par des
conventions internationales auxquelles
nous sommes tous très profondément
attaché il va de soi que ceux qui sont
dégoûtés du droit d'asile peuvent se
retrouver ensuite évidemment face aux
politiques de l'immigration
vous l'avez rappelé mes choix c'est en
termes de principes c'est important
d'affirmer cette séparation entre asile
et politique d'immigration un mot sur le
droit de vote
elle nécessite une réforme
constitutionnelle
c'est au président de la république de
langage et selon les formes qu'il
choisira
j'étais moi
dans une autre ligue nature rapporteur
d'une proposition de loi sur cette
revendication ancienne et c'est un droit
que l'on peut donner à les citoyens qui
ne sont ni français ni membre de l'union
européenne car cela existe déjà pour les
membres de l'union européenne
le seul élément que je peux vous donner
un thème de réflexion personnelle c'est
considérer qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est
peut-être pas un élément d'intégration
supplémentaire ça peut l'être
je ne néglige pas c'est un droit donc il
faut l'intégrer tel quel mais là où je
suis puisque la question du droit de
vote est d'une autre nature
constitutionnelle en tout cas je veux
insister sur la question de la
naturalisation
ces points c'est pour - sans doute
l'élément le plus important j'ai présidé
une mission sur la nationalité à
l'assemblée nationale au moment où je
souhaitais dans une autre assemblée
mettre en cause la double nationalité
j'étais évidemment défavorable mais je
crois très important qu'on insiste sur
ce que représente aujourd'hui la
naturalisation le droit de vote des
résidents étrangers a été porté dans les
années 70 c'est un élément important
notamment vis-à-vis de tous les
travailleurs à l'insu des bières et de
l'italie du maghreb qui était sur notre
sol
aujourd'hui le vrai sujet c'est la
naturalisation et la question le mot et
connaissez ces sujets mal choisi mais
celui de l'intégration de la première de
la deuxième de la troisième génération
de citoyens qui sont français ou qui
souhaitent le devenir et c'est je crois
pour nous tous sans doute la très grande
priorité pour le droit de vote
je vous ai répondu vous savez quelle est
la réforme qu'il faut mener dans ce
domaine là je réponds du coup à la
question de l'accès à la nationalité
française
je vous ai dit que je considérais qu'il
y avait une course d'obstacles qui était
aléatoire et très souvent discriminante
je donnerai un certain nombre de
directives aux préfets que
nous rencontrons avec le premier
ministre de nouveau la semaine prochaine
il faut changer la donne pour mesurer
notamment l'impact de la déconcentration
monsieur le sénateur pas uniquement dans
le nord mettre à plat et reconsidérer
les critères d'accès à la nationalité
l'insertion professionnelle l'emploi les
conditions de ressources la situation
des jeunes celle des conjoints français
encadrent et l'entretien d'assimilation
sénateurs portelli que je retrouve avec
le plaisir il y a par exemple un
questionnaire qui plus proche de jeu
télévisé honnêtement et même des
ministres et peut-être même des
sénateurs et peut-être du mal à y
répondre tellement ils apparaissent je
pense hors des clous mais mais et puis
souvent ces procédures arrive très tard
les agents des préfectures
il faut profondément respecté qui se
trouve face à de véritables difficultés
mérite peut-être d'avoir des outils
performants parce que la question de la
vision à nos valeurs notre histoire nos
langues à ce que notre pays c'est
évidemment très important c'est même est
essentielle mais avec un cadre plus
souple plus pratique et surtout plus
performant en tout cas l'idée ne veut
pas remettre du jour au lendemain en
cause la déconcentration faisons
attention va et vient et au changement
puis parce que surtout lé là où
s'étaient concentrés aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas les agents pour cela mais en
tout cas ce processus d'évaluation pour
arriver à la cohérence et à l'égalité
dans tous les territoires cela me paraît
être un évident avec cet évident pardon
avec cet objectif que j'ai évoqués de ce
point de vue la présidence heures l'a
évoquée je fais attention nous l'avons
dit les uns les autres
souvent et encore vous il ya un instant
il ya eu beaucoup de lois le président
de la république prévue nice nous en
donner à chacun d'entre nous les
ministres une feuille de route légiférer
quand c'est nécessaire
mettez en oeuvre quand c'est possible
pour être efficace la loi les
nécessaires nous l'avons vue suite à la
décision
de la cour de cassation qui a rappliqué
encore une fois des décisions au niveau
européen ça sera nécessaire pour
travailler sur un titre de séjour
cela va de soi mais soyons prudents mais
en tout cas là où la loi est nécessaire
là où la circulaire ne règle pas des
problèmes qui montrerait qu'il ya une
contradiction entre le droit français et
la pratique
oui alors il faudra légiférer de toute
façon c'est votre droit le plus strict
et quand il y aura des textes de loi que
je présentais je n'encourage pas à le
faire systématiquement mais je ne doute
pas que l'initiative de propositions
d'amendements ne manquera pas de votre
votre part est en tout cas il y a la
hiérarchie des normes l'égalité qui sont
des éléments tout à fait essentiel est
que la loi doit faire faire vivre lors
du débat qui se tiendra de ce point de
vue là sur la carte pluriannuel de trois
ans je suis tout à fait disposé à
rediscuter de tout les durcissements
tous les critères qui ont été mises en
place au cours de ces derniers notamment
concernant le regroupement familial et
les restrictions concernant le conjoint
étranger
si on regarde qui sont les signatures
des contrats d'accueil et d'intégration
on s'aperçoit que 73% d'entre eux sont
arrivés en france dans le cadre du
regroupement familial pris au sens le
plus large c'est à dire du fait d'un
lien familial
donc ça nous donne là je crois un chant
qui peut être ne explorer même s'il faut
évidemment savoir discerner
d'éventuelles situations de fraude
cependant à l'occasion des débats que
nous aurons tous les ans au parlement
sur le lien entre économie et
immigration ou à l'occasion des textes
de loi que je vous ne présenterait ou
non du goût
ornements ayons un débat serein sur ces
questions d'émigration concerne les
étudiants et l'un d'entre vous c'est
vous je crois a pertinemment souligné
que c'est pas du jour au lendemain qu'on
fera venir les étudiants étrangers parce
que ça obéit aussi un autre rôle que
celui de la place de la france dans le
monde et notamment là où il ya une
relation forte avec des pays qui nous
sont liés par une histoire notre langue
et lusage donc un défi pour le pays
comme pour nos universités ayant un
débat sur les questions économiques mais
aussi sur le regroupement familial et
lyon aussi
sans langue de bois une réflexion sur
l'accueil de l'immigration de l'autre
pays qui aujourd'hui se passe dans de
mauvaises conditions en termes d'emploi
et de logement et que ce sont les mêmes
villes les mêmes quartiers qui
accueillent une immigration
parfois en difficulté parfois très
pauvre ce qui rajoute aux difficultés et
l'immigration régulière et de nos
compatriotes et il faut avoir aussi ces
éléments en tête si nous voulons avoir
une politique d'immigration qui doit se
jouer évidemment je crois c'est l'un des
grands défis de la planète
il y en a beaucoup aujourd'hui des
immigrations change et on bouleversée
c'est d'abord du sud vers le sud ne
l'oublions pas le monde s'est ouvert
l'immigration qui arrivent en france
n'est pas la même
ya vingt ou trente ou quarante ans cela
change en grande partie nos quartiers
nos villes nos départements avant elle
était concentré sur un certain nombre de
départements
aujourd'hui c'est par tous nos conseils
généraux nos départements nos
préfectures ou du mal à faire face ou
les raisons qui ont été évoqués tout à
l'heure à ces problématiques dont ça
veut dire qu'il faut on ait un débat
difficile le tue pas naïfs et encore
moins angélique mais essayons de le
maîtriser
ce débat c'est important pour notre pays
j'ai répondu sur les naturalisations il
y a le débat sur la durée maximale de
rétention vous l'avez évoqué sur le
président
la durée de 45 jours est une durée
maximale inscrits dans l'endroit mais
qui doivent être amenés à l'utilisation
réelle de la rétention qui est une
mesure coercitive ultime lorsque
l'éloignement ne peut être
lisez par notre moyen et dont la durée
moyenne en métropole le 10 mai en
métropole est d'environ 10 jours et pour
atteindre 45 jours aujourd'hui il faut
que le juge des libertés et de la
détention se soient prononcés par deux
fois sur la prolongation de la rétention
rétention qui à travers toute une série
d'évolutions notamment de notre droit et
du droit européen va connaître des
changements profonds et je souhaiterais
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé avec
la dernière décision de la cour de
cassation que nous soyons gouvernement
et législateurs en capacité d'anticiper
ces évolutions concernant
c'est vrai le droit d'asile c'est vrai
la rétention parce que sinon comme sur
la garde à vue
nous allons nous retrouver face à des
problèmes majeurs d'abord pour notre
administration parce que ils n'auront
pas été anticipée en tout cas je suis
ouvert là aussi un débat sur ces
questions sur les zones d'attentes
flottante se seraient elles existent
elles ont été prévues par le ceseda il
s'agit d'un dispositif qui permet de
faire face à toute une série de
situations exceptionnelles ce ne sont
pas évidemment des lieux de non-droit et
bénéficie de l'ensemble des droits
afférents aux zones d'attentes le
défenseur de droit y est évidemment
attentive le contrôleur aussi je crois
pour ma part je vous réponds en tout cas
précisément qu'il faut
maintenir l'existence de ces zones pour
notre politique de maîtrise des flux
migratoires mais je sais que les
associations habilitées accéder à ces
zones sont critiques
les préfets des départements les plus
susceptibles d'être concernés notamment
sur la façade méditerranéenne ont reçu
instruction de faire ou de préparer des
scénarios de de crise permettant
d'anticiper les lieux les plus probables
de débarquement et d'en déduire les
modalités les plus efficaces en termes
d'hébergement en tout cas je suis
attentif à la garantie des droits de
l'étranger et évidemment aux attentes du
parlement et le contrôleur général des
lieux de privation que je citais il y a
un instant a évoqué avec moi c'est un
sujet je ne peux pas répondre sur
mayotte c'est un vrai sujet enfin je
peux pas répondre en quelques secondes
sur mayotte gg je suis évidemment très
sensible à la qualité du rapport que
vous venez de produire
il était impossible mais monsieur le
sénateur de mayotte l'a dit avec
beaucoup de franchise de considérer que
la situation à mayotte était la même que
celle que nous vivions concernant la
rétention des enfants que celle que nous
vivions en métropole il s'agit là d'un
problème plus général du lien aussi avec
la république des comores et moi je me
tiens à votre disposition et à celle
évidemment des parlementaires de ce
département pour évoquer ces situations
me dis qu'il faut que je parte il ya
évidemment beaucoup de questions sur le
ménage ou bleu blanc rouge est parti
parce que je peux pas je peux pas rater
l'avion on reparlera de la question des
droits
enfin des et que vous avez eu la
gentillesse de mettre à part qui est
celle des gens du voyage je veux vous
dire ma profonde inquiétude sur la
problématique des roms
je ne suis pas sûr d'ailleurs monsieur
le sénateur des français de l'étranger
que aux régles ray uniquement le
problème par la question de l'accès au
travail c'est un des éléments
je ne néglige pas mais ça n'est pas le
seul j'ai rencontré mon homologue
une situation que vous imaginez
politique extrêmement compliqué pour pas
en dire plus
mon homologue romain ministre de
l'intérieur nous menons une politique
commune contre les filières qui exploite
les individus les gens qui se livrent à
des trafics de la prostitution
mais il ya un problème plus général ce
sont des citoyens européens
je crois que il est temps que l'union
européenne rappelle aussi à ces pays où
souvent et je ne le cite pas ces pays
ces gens sont pourchassés vivre en tout
cas de véritable discrimination à leur
obligation mais je suis très inquiet de
la concentration aujourd'hui dans toute
une série de campement il ya des
expériences particulièrement
intéressante y en a eu en région
parisienne il lui à tourcoing d'accueil
d'intégration des familles mais ce sont
des politiques homéopathique
homéopathiques
la situation aujourd'hui à lyon à aix en
provence en seine saint denis dans une
partie de l'agglomération lilloise nous
oblige à prendre des décisions de
démantèlement je ne dis pas que ça règle
la solution mais nous sommes face par
exemple en seine saint denis
parlementaire ce département député me
l'a évoqué hier face à une situation y
compris de confrontation entre des
populations de quartiers populaires et
les populations dites roms est un sujet
que je veux traiter pas facile mais dans
la sérénité
on ne peut les traiter que dans la
sérénité parce que sinon si le débat est
remis sur la place publique de nouveau
la manière dont ça a été fait il y a
deux ans on n'y arrivera pas et c'est là
on aboutit ce sénateur hérisson à la
confusion que vous ne souhaitez pas il
ya un instant entre immigration gens du
voyage gens du voyage français gens du
voyage d'autres nationalités rome et on
ne règle pas le problème et c'est une
situation très difficile 13 vie et elle
m'inquiète
bien évidemment mais là je suis obligé
de partir il ya toute une série de
questions auxquelles je n'ai pas répondu
mais on trouvera j'imagine très vite le
moment pour le faire bien en un mot je
remercie monsieur le ministre nom de
tout le monde je crois qu'on peut vous
on voit bien monsieur le ministre votre
souci de traiter les questions plutôt
que de les exploiter ce qui est toujours
facile
mais on voit aussi qu'il faudra qu'on se
revoie et comptez sur nous pour
continuer à travailler avec vous bien
sûr sur toutes ces questions
un merci manuel valls s'ils ont bien
voilà donc pour l'audition de manuel
valls à suivre l'audition de fleur
pellerin qui a été entendu par les
commissions des affaires économiques et
du développement durable la ministre
délégué à l'économie numérique était en
début d'après midi au sénat tout de
suite direction la salle clemenceau